Welcome.
We're when the master, the disciple, the elder scholar and his student.
And the moment the scholar shows the line, every Muslim utters before every action is a cryptographic seal carrying the architecture of creation.
The Bismillah is the seal.
Three names, 7 letters, 12 letters, locking the architecture closed to whoever rejects its source.
So we are examining sources today that outline this really vast, incredibly intricate cosmological architecture.
We've been looking at the three primordial words, the seven principles, the sevens and 12.
Yeah, the whole foundational structure.
Exactly.
But our mission today is to uncover how this entire design is essentially protected, like who actually populates its highest ranks and how this exact design is permanently written the night sky overhead for you to just, you know, observe.
It is a massive shift from just mapping abstract math to seeing the actual living guides.
Yeah, so to get us started, the scholar explains how this architecture is finished and delivered, and he names.
He does, yeah.
The creator brought it into being through 4 distinct actions.
First, he separated them by his luminescence.
Okay, wait, let's just pause on that first one.
Separated them by his luminescence.
I mean, usually we think of creation as just, you know, popping into existence from nothing.
Sure.
But the teacher is describing a process of differentiation.
What does it actually mean
to separate reality using light.
Well, you have to imagine the state of existence before any forms or boundaries existed at all.
In this cosmology, everything starts as an undifferentiated spiritual reality.
Light isn't just illumination here.
It is the first defining edge.
Like a boundary line?
Exactly.
Luminescence creates the very concept of distinction.
Without that light separating things, there is no space for the next move, which is that he originated them by his command.
Because a command needs a structured space to enter.
Yes.
And after the command, the third move is he created them by his knowledge.
And then finally, the 4th move, he sealed them by their names.
Which is where the paradigm entirely shifts, I think, for anyone listening.
Sealing them by their names.
It sounds like putting a padlock on a vault.
It does.
And the scholar introduces a really fascinating analogy here.
He says, to think of this opening formula as a cipher legible only to the key holder.
A cipher encoded in plain sight.
Encoded in plain sight, recited daily by millions of people, yet it remains totally unread by reciters who lack the covenant.
The seal isn't a piece of wax that you break to read a message.
Okay.
The seal is the text itself.
You read the seal.
I don't buy that yet letter counts as a seal sounds like numerology dressed up.
I mean, it's very easy to assume that.
Yeah, because we're so used to people finding arbitrary patterns, you know, just counting consonants until a hidden message fits their personal theory.
But the master defends against that exact critique.
He shows that this is not numerology.
It's A rigid one-to-one mirror.
It's A blueprint.
For instance, the three names in the formula mirror the three primordial words.
Okay, break those down for me.
The first is erata.
Divine will.
Yes.
The second is msh.
The command.
Exactly.
And the third is qual.
The spoken word.
And those three forces parallel the three letters of nir.
The primordial light.
Okay, I follow that.
Three for three.
Then the structure expands.
The formula contains 7 distinct letters, and those strictly mirror the seven physical heavens.
And then the full formula contains 12
letters mirroring the 12 zodiacs.
So the math of the cosmos is literally baked into the consonants.
Yes.
When you speak it, you are verbally reconstructing the universe.
Which brings in a really vital scriptural precedent.
If we look at the Quran, specifically Solomon's letter to the Queen of Sheba in the chapter on the ants, verse 30, we actually see this in practice.
We do, yeah.
It shows a monarch's missive sealed with this exact line.
And modern scholar Henry Corbin notes,
These letters are the metaphysical alphabet composing the cosmos.
It is the perfect way to phrase it.
Solomon is asserting structural authority by using the seal of the universe itself.
But to understand the inner workings of this architecture, the text uses a lot of paired relationships, male and female language, to describe how layers of reality interact.
That sounds like wordplay.
How is reading male-female as influence different from rewriting words to mean what you want?
It's a fair challenge.
But the master enforces a strict analogy of influence here, not anatomy.
It's the second analogy.
Ranks of influence.
Water influences smoke.
Because it quells it.
Exactly.
And the teacher influences the student.
The active principal transmits.
The receptive principal receives.
So that's why the chapter on the Winnowing Winds, verse 49, where it says, created 2 mates, that presents pairing as a cosmic sign pointing to the unpaired source.
You've got it.
is entirely about the physics of spiritual authority.
Okay, so the math holds the building together, the seal is on the door, and the transmission dynamics are set.
But an empty building is just a monument.
It has to be populated.
The apex has to be filled with living personalities, not just abstract concepts.
Yes, so the scholar pivots here to the chosen ranks.
A clear hierarchy placed directly in the houses of prophethood.
At the absolute pinnacle sits the Natik.
The speaker of the revealed path.
Followed by the Imam.
The supreme guide.
Yeah.
And below that station is the Hujjah.
Meaning the proof.
Exactly.
Alongside the Nu Kaaba.
The chieftains.
Then you have the Duat.
The summoners calling the seekers.
And finally the Ulama.
The scholars preserving the record.
That living chain really changes how you interact with everything.
I mean, we remember the prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, the one whose houses of prophethood are populated by these exact figures.
Yes, they are his houses.
And the scripture backs this up.
The chapter on the B, verse 43, sends the unknowing to these specific guides.
It says to ask the people the reminder.
It doesn't say just read harder.
It points to humans.
And the commander of the faithful brings us into an incredibly sharp focus.
And peak of eloquence.
Yes.
He states the earth is
Never void of the standing proof.
The sermon collection repeats this.
It is a continuous office, not a historical accident, not a random burst of charisma.
It's A structural feature.
Without the standing proof, the whole architecture has no terrestrial anchor.
Which is where Farha Daftari makes that incredible connection.
The mathematical signature of sevens, 12s, and 30s that organizes the heavens.
It is the exact same arithmetic organizing this personnel.
Yes, 12 zodiacs mirror 12 guides.
30 lunar days mirror the ranks of 30.
The Bismillah is the seal.
Three names, 7 letters, 12 letters locking the architecture closed to whoever rejects its source.
And to make sure you never forget that, the master introduces his final analogy, the night sky as a silent recitation.
A silent recitation.
Key is mirrored perfectly overhead.
Think of the sun.
The sun is the leader, but it is veiled by its own immense brightness.
You can't stare at it.
Right, it blinds you.
So there has to be an intermediary.
And that intermediary is the moon.
The moon corresponds to the bab.
It doesn't generate its own light.
It translates the sun's overwhelming brilliance into a cool glow that the seeker can actually look at.
And the stars.
The stars correspond to the summoners scattered across the dark to give you orientation.
That connects directly to navigation.
The chapter on the B, verse 16, says, and by the stars they are guided.
Wayfarers use physical stars for travel, but seekers use the summoners for spiritual travel.
Exactly.
But there is a very hard distinction here.
A strict numerical reality.
There are 12 regional hujaj distributed across the earth.
12 regional proofs.
But there is only one gateway per leader.
The single gateway proof known as the Huja Al-Imam.
So just as there are 12 mansions in the zodiac.
There's only one moon traversing them.
I can see the absolute brilliance of this design.
I really do.
Earlier I questioned if the letter counts and paralanguage were just, you know, dressed up numerology.
But when you lay it all out from the three primordial words to the mathematical seal, the living hierarchy, and the stars,
It's undeniable.
It is a unified architecture.
Corbin's celestial terrestrial mirror makes it so clear.
The nice guy is quite literally a daytime teaching recited silently overhead.
The bismila is the seal.
Three names, 7 letters, 12 letters, locking the architecture closed to whoever rejects its source.
Which ordinary line in your own day recited a dozen times without notice carries a meaning you have never paused to read.
And what would it cost this week to open one such utterance slowly enough to recognize what it has been signing?